[Musique]
de large couloir plus de strapontin pour
offrir plus de place en heure creuses et
de la couleur la Société du Grand Paris
Alstom vient de dévoiler le design
intérieur des rames de la future ligne
18 du nouveau métro francilien les
usagers trouveront également des prises
USB des écrans d'information à
l'intérieur des rames ils pourront aussi
bénéficier de la connexion 4G et 5G les
futurs rames pourront transporter 350
passagers conçus dans le cas du Grand
Paris Express la ligne s'étendra sur 35
km entre Orly et Versailles à l'horizon
2030 et des servira trois gares dans les
Yvelines notre chiffre du jour 185 c'est
le nombre de kilomètres de voies qui
seront réservés en Île-de-France pendant
la période des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 ces axes seront
accessibles aux athlètes à tous les
membres des délégations olympiques au
secours resto journaliste accrédités ces
portions sont également réservées au
taxis aux véhicules de transport en
commun dans les Yvelines la portion de
l'autoroute sur la 13 entre le
chesnérocancourt et Saint-Cloud est
concern elle était fermée depuis le 7
juin 2022 la médiathèque des 7 Mares
rouvre ses portes le mardi 21 février
les travaux auront permis une rénovation
de l'isolation du bâtiment une
restauration de la façade et une
réorganisation pour valoriser les
collections une fête de réouverture sont
organisée les 15 et 18 mars il y aura du
sport ce week-end avec les quarts de
finale de la Coupe des Yvelines l'équipe
3 demande jouera contre l'équipe 2 de
Conflans Aubergenville recevra l'équipe
3 de Versailles Sartrouville 2 ira défi
Rambouillet et Les Mureaux de affront au
lieu de les rencontres sont programmées
ce dimanche à 15h il faudra s'ammer de
patience ce week-end sur les routes de
la région parisienne avec le début des
vacances d'hiver quelques perturbations
sont à prévoir vendredi Bison Futé voit
orange dans le sens des départs en
Île-de-France il est conseillé de
quitter ou de traverser la région avant
11h samedi le trafic devrait s'améliorer
en Île-de-France mais les conditions de
circulation seront très difficiles si
vous vous rendez vers les stations de
ski dans les Alpes les Vosges ou le Jura
[Musique]